♪ ♪
>> Martha: TONIGHT, SENATE
DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING FOR THE
PENTAGON TO LAUNCH AN
INDEPENDENT INSPECTOR GENERAL’S
INVESTIGATION INTO THE NAVY’S
DECISION TO BELIEVE THE CAPTAIN
OF THE USS THEODORE ROOSEVELT
FROM HIS POST.
CAPTAIN BRECK ROZIER, AS YOU SEE
HERE, SOME OF THE
ALARM FOR SAILORS ABOARD THE CAR
HE CALLED FOR THE SHIP’S
IMMEDIATE EVACUATION AFTER MORE
THAN 100 SAILORS TESTED POSITIVE
ON BOARD.
THE ACTING SECRETARY OF THE NAVY
SAYS THAT THE CAPTAIN ACTED
WITHOUT DISCUSSING THE LETTER
WITH HIS IMMEDIATE COMMANDER AND
SENT A LETTER OVER AN UNSECURED,
UNCLASSIFIED EMAIL SYSTEM.
>> IT WAS COPIED TO 20 OR 30
OTHER PEOPLE, OKAY?
THAT’S JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE.
HE DID NOT TAKE CARE AND WHAT
THAT DATE IS CREATE A PANIC, A
LITTLE BIT OF A PANIC ON THE
SHIP.
THAT DEMONSTRATED EXTREMELY POOR
JUDGMENT IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CRISIS, BECAUSE WHAT IT’S DONE
IS CREATE A FIRESTORM, IT’S
CREATIVE DOUBTS ABOUT THE SHIP’S
ABILITY TO GO TO SEE IF IT NEEDS
TO, IT’S CREATED DOUBT AMONG THE
FAMILIES ABOUT THE HEALTH OF
THEIR SAILORS AND THAT WAS A
COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY THING TO
DO IN THE MIDST OF CRISIS.
>> Martha: JOINING ME NOW,
GENERAL JACK KEANE, FOUR STAR
GENERAL AND FOX NEWS STRATEGIC
ANALYST.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON THIS STORY?
>> I THINK IT’S PRETTY
UNFORTUNATE, CIRCUMSTANCES
TAKING PLACE HERE BECAUSE
EVERYBODY INVOLVED HERE IS
WELL-INTENTIONED.
AND YOU KNOW, MY FIRST ISSUE
WITH IT IS THE SECRETARY OF THE
NAVY PIER TO LISTEN, HE IS
COMPLETELY JUSTIFIED IN TAKING
THE ACTIONS OF THE REASONS HE
STATED, BUT WHY IS HE DOING THAT
IS THE
QUESTION I’M ASKING.
HE’S GOT AT LEAST FOUR ADMIRALS
BETWEEN HIM AND HIS CAPTAIN.
THAT’S OVER 100 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
NAVY OPERATIONS.
IF YOU’VE GOT A CONCERN ABOUT
SOMEBODY WHO IS RUNNING THE MOST
POWERFUL SYMBOL OF AMERICAN
POWER IN THIS COUNTRY, WHICH IS
AN AIRCRAFT CARRIER, LET THOSE
ADMIRALS MAKE THAT ASSESSMENT
AND MAKE THE JUDGMENT ABOUT
THAT.
BUT THE NAVY SECRETARY GOT
HIMSELF PERSONALLY INVESTED IN
THIS.
I UNDERSTAND HE MAY HAVE HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE CAPTAIN
LAST WEEK.
SO, THAT’S ISSUE ONE FOR ME AND
IF YOU ARE DOING THAT, IF YOU’RE
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS AND NOT
LETTING THE ADMIRAL MAKE THE
DECISIONS AT LOWER LEVELS,
AREN’T YOU GOING AROUND THE
CHAIN OF COMMAND AND WEAKENING
THAT CHAIN OF COMMAND IN DOING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
IN MY JUDGMENT, THAT’S TRUE.
BUT I WILL GO BACK TO, HE HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO DO IT.
SECONDLY, WHY DO IT NOW?
THE ROOSEVELT IS NOT
OPERATIONALLY DEPLOYED.
THERE IS A STRIKE COMMAND GROUP
ON THAT SHIP THAT IS STILL
FUNCTIONING AND THEY HAVE
CONTROL OF THE OTHER SHIPS, BUT
THE SHIP’S COMPANY BY AND LARGE
ARE ALL FOCUSED ON ONE.
ON CHILDREN, ON ISOLATION AND
TESTING THE CREW AND GETTING THE
NOW 140 WHO ARE ILL TAKING CARE
OF.
90 SOMETHING OF THEM ARE
SYMPTOMATIC.
WE ALL KNOW THAT A NAVY CAPTAIN
IS A LARGER-THAN-LIFE FIGURE ON
A SHIP.
EVERYBODY HAS AN OPINION ABOUT
THAT CAPTAIN WHO SERVES ON THAT
TRIP.
MOST OF THEM ARE VERY FAVORABLE
BECAUSE WE’VE GOT GREAT PEOPLE
OUT THERE SERVING, AND TO REMOVE
THAT PERSON IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CRISIS THAT’S THREATENING THE
LIVES OF THE PEOPLE ON THAT SHIP
SEEMS TO ME THE TIMING IS OFF.
LET’S MAKE A JUDGMENT ABOUT THE
MISTAKE HE MAY HAVE MADE, BUT
LET HIM CONTINUE THERE UNTIL THE
FULL ASSESSMENT IS COMPLETED AND
LET’S GET SOME EMOTIONAL
SEPARATION FROM THIS.
THE THIRD THING IS THE CAPTAIN
HIMSELF.
I MEAN, WHY WOULD HE WRITE A
LETTER AFTER HE’S HAD PLENTY OF
DIALOGUE WITH HIS CHAIN OF
COMMAND ON A NONSECURE NET, AND
THEN COPY PEOPLE ON THAT LETTER
WHO ARE NOT IN HIS CHAIN OF
COMMAND?
SOME OF THEM ARE SUBORDINATE TO
HIM.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY A BONEHEADED
MISTAKE, IN MY VIEW.
DESPITE THE FACT IS
WELL-INTENTIONED.
OBVIOUSLY, HE WAS TALKING TO HIS
CHAIN OF COMMAND BEFORE THEY GOT
TO GUAM.
VERY HIGH IN THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND, AND THEY KNEW HE HAD A
LOT OF CONCERN.
THEY WERE WORKING ON TRYING TO
GET HIM THE NEEDS AND AT SOME
POINT OVER THE WEEKEND, I’M
CONVINCED HE MUST HAVE COME TO
THE CONCLUSION, HEY, LISTEN,
THEY’RE NOT MOVING FAST ENOUGH,
I’VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS.
AND THAT SPARKED THE LETTER.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO
HANDLE THAT.
THE WHOLE CHAIN OF COMMAND, IF
HE WANTED THEM ON A VPC TO TALK
TO THEM ABOUT THE PROBLEM, HE’S
GOT TO INCLUDE THE CHIEF OF
NAVAL OPERATIONS AND GO ALL THE
WAY TO THE TOP WITH EVERYONE
ELSE.
HE WOULD’VE GOTTEN THAT VTC
WITHOUT ANY PROBLEM WHATSOEVER.
WHY DO THAT?
AND THAT JUDGMENT CALL IS WHAT
IS THE ISSUE HERE.
>> Martha: AND, IT MAY BE ONE
THAT HE REGRETS, I HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT AS YOU SAY, HE CLEARLY GOT
TO THE POINT, OR I WOULD ASSUME,
JUST FROM THE SEQUENCE OF
EVENTS, THAT HE GOT TO THE POINT
WHERE HE FELT LIKE NOBODY WAS
LISTENING TO HIM AND HIS PEOPLE
WERE IN A BAD SITUATION THAT HE
WANTED TO HELP THEM OUT OF.
LISTEN TO THIS VIDEO.
THIS IS THEM CHEERING HIM ON AS
HE WAS LEAVING THE SHIP.
THEY ARE CHANTING "CAPTAIN
CROZIER."
[ALL CHANTING "CAPTAIN CROZIER"]
>> Martha: THAT’S A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO SEEM TO THINK HE HAD
THEIR BACKS.
>> TO MY POINT, HE’S A
LARGER-THAN-LIFE FIGURE ON THAT
SHIP.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHO HE IS AND
YOU CAN SEE THE SEND-OFF THAT
HE’S GETTING FROM ANY OF THE
CREW MEMBERS.
MANY CREWMEMBERS DON’T AGREE
WITH THAT DECISION.
THEY ARE EMOTIONALLY INVESTED IN
THIS THEMSELVES.
IT’S AN UNFORTUNATE SITUATION, I
THINK IT COULD’VE BEEN BETTER
HANDLED.
I BELIEVE WHEN YOU ARE DEALING
WITH ISSUES THAT TAKE PLACE IN
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND, THOSE WHO
ARE CLOSEST TO THAT CHAIN OF
COMMAND, THEY KNOW THE FACTS,
THEN OTHER PEOPLE INVOLVED, LET
THEM MAKE THEIR DECISIONS AND
THE ASSESSMENT ABOUT THAT.
SOME PEOPLE IN THE PENTAGON
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT A GUY
WHO’S RUNNING RUNNING THE SHIP
OUT IN THE PACIFIC --
>> Martha: RIGHT.
>> I THINK THAT’S
WELL-INTENTIONED.
YOU HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO IT
BUT I THINK WERE BETTER SERVED
IF WE LEAVE IT TO PEOPLE MUCH
CLOSER TO THE PROBLEM.
>> Martha: GENERAL KEANE,
ALWAYS GOOD TO GET YOUR